hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another oculus rift game
called don't let go for anything no
never please don't let go now this isn't
necessarily a horror game I don't think
but I was a little confused because when
I got in here I just seem to be in this
little office here that says SkyDome
Studios on the door I was expecting like
a cliff or something but anyway the
concept is you got to hold down the
control buttons and not let go no matter
what so let's get into it there's not
much else to say basic sorry oh hi and
thank you for playing my game ok if
you're not playing with headphones right
now I am these go get them you know
gonna be much better if you have
headphones okay you start the game
uh-huh press both control keys on your
keyboard
uh-huh if you want to win don't let go
okay whatever you say man let's get into
it oh oh hey fly whoa
that ceiling is disgusting oh hey
there's more hi there friends how you
doing oh my god is that a bead ah
another piece anything but the bees Oh
oh my god there's a lot of bees the
hell's going on here okay so oh they
seem to be dissipating a bit that's cool
well I mean other than that that wasn't
that bad
bita for you Mike oh excuse me hi yeah
open the door get on the floor everybody
excuse me you want to back up a step
oh my okay that yeah that is just a
little bit good okay uh all right you
know sometimes I forget just how good
the oculus rifts 3d actually is it's uh
rather strange how accurate that can be
anyway so uh so yeah
okay all right that's good I like that
those are knives oh hi well yeah this
isn't scary enough for you maybe not did
you know there's a giant spider behind
this lepto it really wants to meet you
oh good for it oh good so this is where
the horror portion of it comes from
warning spiders I don't technically have
arachnophobia I don't particularly love
spiders but I don't like them I guess
it's good oh hey uh huh that's a giant
spider that's like a average big spider
it's not like that guy okay
all right that's what you're too now hey
hey friend are you doing got a new
friend here where you going
where where's he going I can't see him
ah ah he's crawling in my breath oh that
ah he's crawling to my brain yeah I
always had enough good head bowed out of
my ear oh is crunching it's like that it
needs a crunching back here nothing okay
I think you burrowed into my brain well
you're gonna be sorely disappointed when
you find that there's not much in there
for you hi
that mesmerizing what are we summoning a
knife demon here what is going on oh
they're floating okay so far so good I'm
sure that these totally aren't gonna
stab into my eyeballs at any given
moment
like what is the point in not letting go
I mean if I was in an office I would let
go of my laptop you know oh did you
stand here okay
what you gonna do huh bring it on
Joce yeah it's burrowing out of my brain
down about brain and calling up my head
seriously these headphones are too good
kiss you son of a [ __ ] ah I don't I
don't hate writers but I hate that okay
well I give up congratulations
okay win that well actually let me try
it one more thing okay bring it on
oh my oh hey I got my ears ah oh hi my
god you tricky bastard I think I can let
go now right oh man every day
I cringe so much at that one part I was
actually my eyes were totally shut so I
couldn't see if anyone anything was
actually happening ah
and then my oculus have like drifted up
on my head so everything was hilter's
killed her but anyway oh man that was
really fun it was really cool you guys
got to try that if you got oculus rift
try it good headphones too because wow
it was in my ear I thought the fly was
bad but that thing yeah it made your gig
crawl you know your guy crawl all over
the place but anyway that was a whole
lot of fun links in the description give
it a try like it was awesome I want to
see how other people reacted to that so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more the use it I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
know what really would make